so und jetzt sind wir bei dem
Tagesordnungspunkt angekommen
der eigentlich schon vor nein mindestens
einer guten halben Stunde vorgesehen war
es geht um das Thema Impfpflicht auch
diese Debatte haben sie ja mit
Sicherheit in den kommenden Monaten
intensiv verfolgt es geht um
Gesetzentwürfe mit unterschiedlichen
Vorschlägen was eine Impfpflicht angeht
es geht um Anträge aus
Fraktionen aber auch noch mal um einen
Gruppenantrag beispielsweise um den
FDP-Politiker Kubicki die eine
Impfpflicht generell ablehnen dann gibt
es die gruppenanträge aus verschiedenen
Fraktionen die eine Impfpflicht ab 18
vorsehen es gibt eine Variante wo es
zunächst eine Beratung geben soll und an
eine Impfpflicht wenn diese Beratung und
die Impfquote sich nicht erfüllt mir ist
dann geben soll eine Impfpflicht ab
beispielsweise 50 Jahren also
verschieden liegen auf dem Tisch eine
deutliche nötige Mehrheit hat bislang
keiner dieser Gesetzentwürfe und
Anträgen
haben die
reedereihenfolge und die
Rede zu dass wir beim Aufruf der
Rednerinnen und Redner nicht die
Fraktionen mit benennen sondern
gegebenenfalls die Gruppen oder eben die
Fraktion wenn es sich um einen
fraktionsantrag handelt
die erste Rednerin ist Heike Behrens von
der Gruppe Behrens und andere
so das war noch mal Erläuterung von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin katrin
Göring-Eckardt die werden wir übrigens
heute öfter sehen genauso wie Petra Pau
den die beiden müssen sich aus
verschiedenen Gründen die
Sitzungsleitung heute Morgen und ja
heute und morgen durchweg teilen also
immer zwei Stunden Schichten und jetzt
Heike Bärens die für den Antrag
generelle Impfpflicht ab 18 spricht
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen stellen Sie
sich vor wir hätten heute bereits eine
Impfquote von
90%. dann steckten wir nicht fest in der
größten Infektionswelle seit Beginn der
Pandemie Deutschland hat
Deutschland hat europaweit die höchste
Inzidenz einzelne krankenhäuser müssen
wieder Operationen verschieben höchste
Anspannung und Belastung für das
Personal was für ein Trauerspiel wieder
und wieder müssen wir erkennen dass
Virus ist nicht berechenbar es reicht
eben nicht aus nur auf die aktuelle
Situation zu reagieren wir müssen
grundlegend die Voraussetzung dafür
schaffen dass wir nicht noch einmal von
einer weiteren Infektionswelle überrollt
werden und darum setze ich mich
gemeinsam mit 236 Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus vier Fraktionen für eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht für alle
Erwachsenen in Deutschland ein
wir wollen unsere Gesellschaft und unser
Gesundheitswesen vor Überlastung
schützen dazu müssen wir eine hohe
Grundimmunisierung aufbauen und wir
wissen seit langem und können dies in
anderen Ländern sehen je mehr Menschen
durch Impfung vor einer corona-infektion
geschützt sind umso weniger Menschen
erkranken schwer umso schneller können
wir zu einem gesellschaftlichen Leben
ohne
freiheitseinschränkende Schutzmaßnahmen
zurückkehren danach sehnen wir uns alle
und das ist dringend nötig für unsere
Kinder und Jugendlichen für unsere
Wirtschaft für alle die Tag und Nacht um
das Leben von schwer erkrankten Menschen
Ringen und auch sich um pflegebedürftige
kümmern
um vor die Welle zu kommen müssen wir
eine hohe Impfquote bis zum Herbst
erreicht haben durch Information
Aufklärung Beratung und eben auch eine
impfnachweispflicht die auch
kontrolliert wird unser Gesetzentwurf
ist gut begründet und solide
ausgestaltet mit ihm werben wir hier und
heute dafür gemeinsam diesen echten Weg
der Vorsorge zu beschreiten ich wende
mich an alle
verantwortungsbewussten DemokratInnen
und Demokraten im Deutschen Bundestag an
die nachdenklichen und die
unentschlossenen
an die denen es wichtig ist die im
Skeptiker noch besser zu beraten zu
informieren und zu überzeugen an die die
ernsthaft für den Herbst vorsorgen
wollen weil sie das Gemeinwohl im Blick
haben lassen Sie uns gemeinsam den
Konsens suchen für einen nachhaltigen
Weg diese Pandemie unter Kontrolle zu
bringen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union wenn Sie Ihren Antrag zur
Impfpflicht Vorsorge
nicht heute sondern vor vier Monaten
eingebracht hätten dann müssten sie
heute im Angesicht der aktuellen
dramatischen infektionslage zu der
Erkenntnis kommen es braucht den
impfmechanismus wie Sie es nennen jetzt
denn nur dann werden diejenigen die
heute noch nicht geimpft sind die
notwendige grundimmunität bis zum Herbst
erreicht haben und darum bitte warten
Sie nicht länger ab sehen Sie der
Realität ins Auge gehen Sie mit uns den
Weg der Vernunft und der Vorsorge die
unserem Gemeinwohl dienen vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Heike Behrens für die Gruppe derer die
eine Impfpflicht ab 18 befürworten und
dafür um Unterstützung werben nächster
Redner ist Sepp Müller
unionsfraktions-quote nicht erreicht ist
und eine bestimmte Lage eingetreten dann
solle man erst über eine Impfpflicht
reden hören wir im Zug wir stehen noch
alle unter dem tiefen Eindruck der
heutigen Rede des Staatspräsidenten
selenski aus der Ukraine und er sprach
von einer Mauer und lieber ampelparteien
anscheinend haben sie eine Mauer in dem
Kopf wenn wir eine Debatte nach dieser
Rede über die Impfpflicht in Deutschland
im Bundestag führen das geht gar nicht
Menschen sterben
Bomben fliegen auf Theater wo Kinder
Schutz suchen und wir führen in diesem
Haus eine Debatte zur Impfpflicht
und wenn wir den Bundeskanzler sehen der
Gott sei Dank heute da ist dann wäre das
das Mindeste gewesen Herr Bundeskanzler
dass Sie dazu eine Regierungserklärung
abgeben
ohne Anstand ohne würde und ohne Respekt
dem Staatspräsidenten gegenüber sein
gesagt es stehen zu lassen ohne eine
Antwort zu geben das ist diesem
Parlament geschätzte frau Präsidentin
unwürdig
[Applaus]
und wenn wir uns die
Situation in der Ukraine anschauen
[Musik]
dann ist das nicht nur bedrückend
sondern dann ist diese Situation für uns
alle auch schwer in Worte zu fassen und
deswegen ist das vielleicht auch die
Sprachlosigkeit der Ampel weil sie in
vielen Punkten keine Mehrheit haben ein
Kollege sprach das an wie wird denn die
Ausgestaltung des Sondervermögens von
100 Milliarden Euro aussehen wie ist
denn ihre Meinung und die Kollegin von
den Grünen sprach von Parteipolitik wenn
ich die Grüne Jugend aus Berlin in
sozialen Medien lese die sagen für 100
Milliarden Euro könnte man 20 Milliarden
Hamster kaufen dann ist das unwürdig
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und
Parteipolitik
und schauen wir uns dann auch diese
Ampel an dann hat sie nicht nur bei
diesem großen staatspolitischen
Herausforderungen keine Mehrheit sondern
auch bei der Debatte die der
Bundeskanzler gewünscht hat nämlich beim
Thema Impfpflicht man muss doch ganz
deutlich sagen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
ist die Impfpflicht tot es gibt keine
Mehrheit in diesem Haus für eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht ab 18 und wir als
Unionsfraktion
die während der orientierungsdebatte
vom Professor Lauterbach als
Gesundheitsminister per Tweet beschimpft
wurde während unser Redner hier vorne
standen dass wir das parteipolitisch
ausschlachten würden wir haben uns
Gedanken gemacht mit Expertinnen und
Experten gesprochen und einen Vorschlag
gemacht der eint und nicht wie ihre
Vorschläge dieses Parlament trennt meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
und wir haben mit 197 Abgeordneten einen
Antrag der mehrheitsfähig ist und
deswegen bitte schließen Sie sich auch
an denn wir wollen drei Dinge erstens
ein impfregister damit wir überhaupt
wissen wer geimpft ist und dadurch eine
Impfkampagne auf dem Weg bringen können
zweitens einen 14-tägigen Bericht der
Bundesregierung insbesondere
Gesundheitsministers damit er das nicht
immer bei Anne Will erklären muss
sondern auch mal den Parlament erklären
kann und drittens meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ein vorsorgemechanismus
wenn eines dieser Papiere zu dem
Entschluss kommt dass eine tödliche
Variante da ist so tödlich wie Delta und
so anstrengend wie ommikron dann würden
wir mit einem Mechanismus auch eine
Impfpflicht nach altersgehorten
entsprechend Scharfschalten all das ist
ein einigen der Vorschlag der liegt auf
den Tisch und da bitten wir um
Zustimmung
Sepp Müller stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der Unionsfraktion hat ein
paar Minuten gebraucht um zum Thema zu
kommen ist dann aber noch erwischt und
ein wenig erläutert wie der Antrag der
Unionsfraktion in diesem Debatte zu
diesem Thema aussieht jetzt Alice Weidel
afd-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
die vorliegenden Anträge für eine
Impfpflicht in verschiedenen Spielarten
sind das Produkt von verbohrter
Besessenheit und
ignoranter Tatsachen Verweigerung
Deutschland steht mit dieser absurden
und anachronistischen Debatte wieder
einmal als europäischer Sonderling da
selbst unsere Nachbarn in Österreich
haben das Vorhaben Impfpflicht vorerst
ausgesetzt die Impfpflicht ist auf
falschen Tatsachenbehauptung aufgebaut
das eine Impfung
andere wirksam vor Ansteckung schützt
und die Ausbreitung des Virus dämpft
sind Fake News sie sind falsch das muss
sogar das Robert-Koch-Institut zugeben
wer versprochene Schutz vor schweren
Verläufen ist ebenfalls fragwürdig
angesichts des wachsenden Anteils von
geimpften und gebusterten auf den
Intensivstationen eine das
Gesundheitssystem gefährdende
Überlastung der krankenhäus da gab es
nie es gibt sie nicht sie droht auch
nicht das hat im übrigen der
Gesundheitsminister unfreiwillig zugeben
müssen eine Impfpflicht ist auch nicht
erforderlich um lockdowns im Herbst zu
verhindern lockdowns verhindert man
indem die Regierung keine verhängt so
einfach ist das die Nutzlosigkeit und
Schädlichkeit von lockdowns sollte sich
inzwischen herumgesprochen haben dagegen
sind aber die potenziellen
Nebenwirkungen der mRNA und
vektorimpfstoffe weitaus schwerer und
weiter verbreitet als ursprünglich
behauptet wann wird darüber eigentlich
mal in diesem Hause gesprochen
die Argumente für eine Impfpflicht waren
von Anfang an schwach und sie sind auch
inzwischen wie ein Kartenhaus in sich
zusammengefallen es gibt keine legitime
und verfassungsrechtlich zulässige
Rechtfertigung für die Einführung einer
Impfpflicht gegen kobit 19 egal ob als
Impfpflicht ab 18 ab 50 Impfpflicht aus
als Vorrat oder einrichtungsbezogen eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht verletzt zentrale
Grundrechte die Menschenwürde das Recht
auf Leben und körperliche Unversehrtheit
und das Recht auf die Glaubens und
Gewissensfreiheit die
Verhältnismäßigkeit die einen derart
schweren Grundrechtseingriff
legitimieren würde ist nicht gegeben die
Impfpflicht ist nicht geeignet um die
angestrebten Ziele zu erreichen sie ist
auch nicht erforderlich da es andere und
viel mildere Therapien und Maßnahmen
gibt und sie ist auch nicht angemessen
dem Staat ist nicht erlaubt Leben und
Gesundheit einiger Bürger zu gefährden
um andere Bürger zu schützen die
Begründung eine Impfpflicht sei
notwendig um eine Überlastung der
Krankenhäuser zu verhindern ist nicht
nur falsch sie ist gefährlich nach
dieser pseudologik könnte man Menschen
künftig allen möglichen Behandlung auf
nötigen von der pflichtmedikation von
bluthochdruckgefährdeten bis hin zur
zwangsdiät für Übergewichtige und zur
Begründung reicht ein politisch selbst
hergestellter kapazitätsengpass ich
hoffe sie merken selbst wie absurd das
ist die Impfpflicht ist ein Akt der
Entrechtung
sie erniedrigt Millionen Menschen von
souveränen mit freiheits- und
abwehrrechten ausgestatteten Individuen
zu Befehlsempfängern und Objekten
staatlicher Willkür sie treibt Millionen
Menschen sie treibt Millionen Menschen
in Gewissenskonflikte und existenzielle
Nöte sehr geehrte Kollegen von
Regierungsfraktionen Union die sie einen
der vorliegenden impfpflichtanträge
unterstützen sie reiten ein totes Pferd
bitte steigen sie ab ziehen Sie diese
Anträge zurück und lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam den ihr Weg der
einrichtungsbezogenen Pflege Impfpflicht
so schnell wie möglich beenden
so schnell wie möglich Frau Kollegen
kommen Sie zum Schluss mit uns in diesem
schweren Zeiten nicht leisten auch da
sind und rechthabereidige Gesellschaft
mit einer Impfpflicht noch weiter zu
spalten für die es weder medizinisch
noch rechtlich eine Begründung gibt ich
bedanke mich
der Bundestag diskutiert über
verschiedene Initiativen zum Thema
Impfpflicht die reichen von kompletter
Ablehnung bis zu einer Impfpflicht ab 18
gibt es auch noch die Varianten die er
in die Zukunft gerichtet sind gegen eine
Impfpflicht in jeglicher Form ist Manuel
Höferlin und der ist in der FDP-Fraktion
und innenpolitischer sprecherwort
wer eine Impfpflicht einführen will der
muss erklären wozu diese genau führen
soll und die Fragen die sich mir Stellen
sind schaffen wir mit der Impfung eine
herdenimmunität die Antwort ist nein
schützen schützt die Impfung sicher vor
Ansteckung nein
schützt die Impfung vor Ansteckung
anderer nein
verhindern wir mit der Impfpflicht eine
Infektionswelle im kommenden Herbst die
Antwort ist nein keine Frage meine Damen
und Herren die Impfung schützt mich
wahrscheinlich vor einem schweren
Verlauf und ziemlich sicher vor dem Tod
deswegen habe ich mich auch impfen
lassen boosterlassen meine Familie hat
das gemacht und ich empfehle es mit
Nachdruck jedem zu machen und dafür zu
werben
daraus resultiert aber nicht die Pflicht
zu einer Impfung diese Pflicht
einzuführen ohne eine Antwort auf die
Frage zu finden ob es nicht die mildere
omegonvariante dazu führt andere
Bewertungsmaßstäbe zu anzulegen die
halte ich für problematisch meine Damen
und Herren mittlerweile haben sich die
Infektionszahlen auch von den
Krankenhausbehandlungen von der Belegung
der Intensivstationen abgekoppelt und
die Prognosen manche dass die
Intensivstationen nun volllaufen oder
noch anders dass sie es nicht tun wenn
wir jetzt eine Impfpflicht einführen das
entbehrt jeder Grundlage
keine europäische Demokratie hat aktuell
die Pflicht zur Impfung selbst
österreich hat sie gerade wieder außer
Vollzug gesetzt mit der
nachvollziehbaren Begründung unter der
omegonvariante ergeben sie keinen Sinn
mehr
meine Damen und Herren ja wir müssen die
vulvernablen Gruppen schützen aber nicht
vor sich selbst
denn zu behaupten für deren Schutz
bräuchte es eine Impfpflicht das trägt
nicht diejenigen die bis jetzt nicht
geimpft sind die wollen sich
wahrscheinlich nicht impfen lassen und
vielleicht tragen sie auch lieber eine
Maske um sich zu schützen das ist ihre
Entscheidung und übrigens ist das auch
ihr gutes Recht das zu tun nach zwei
Jahren Pandemie sollten wir den Menschen
aber wieder eigene Entscheidungen
zutrauen für staatliche Bevormundungen
ist weder Zeit noch rechtlicher Raum und
unsere Verfassung meine Damen und Herren
sieht das schlicht nicht vor
statt Zwang wäre Einsicht das Gebot der
Stunde doch die angekündigten
Impfkampagnen die mit viel Geld
finanziert und entweder verpufft sind
oder noch auf ihre Umsetzung warten dazu
machen wir einen Amt in unserem Antrag
konkrete Vorschläge und lassen Sie mich
noch einmal klarstellen die Entscheidung
über die eigene Gesundheit und das
eigene Leben liegt am Ende immer noch
bei jedem selbst
in der Verantwortung von uns im
Deutschen Bundestag liegt es aber
hingegen bei anderen Erkenntnisse auch
andere Wege zu gehen was im letzten
Herbst noch gegolten hat ist nach der
heutigen Erkenntnislage vielleicht
anders und deshalb lassen sie uns heute
und im weiteren Verlauf offen und
ehrlich diskutieren nicht nur darüber
was als nötig empfunden wird sondern was
wirklich Bürgerinnen und Bürgern hilft
und was rechtlich möglich ist herzlichen
Dank
Manuel Höfer liegen in diesem Fall nicht
für die komplette FDP-Fraktion aber die
in der FDP und den anderen Fraktionen
die gegen eine impfpflichte sind und wir
bleiben quasi bei der FDP aber bei einer
ganz kommen zu einer ganz anderen
Position nämlich zu der von Android
Ulmen und anderen Abgeordneten im
Parlament die sich für eine
Beratungslösung und eine Impfpflicht bei
Bedarf aussprechen
wollen das Gesundheitssystem vor
Überlastung schützen und diese
Überlastung können wir nur Schütze indem
wir die Krankheitslast reduzieren und
eine krankheitsleistung nur dann
reduziert werden wir eine gewisse
Grundimmunisierung in unserer
Bevölkerung haben und das ist das
Fundament das wir brauchen unser Weg ist
aber ein anderer ein Ziel ist relativ
klar ausgesprochen unser Weg das
Gesetzesentwurfes sagt klar wir
vertrauen dem Menschen eine richtige
Entscheidung zu treffen nur um diese
richtige Entscheidung zu treffen bedarf
es einer professionellen guten
Aufklärung und deshalb setzen wir uns ja
auch dafür ein eine verpflichtende
Aufklärung für diejenigen in den Weg zu
auf den Weg zu bringen damit sie eine
gute Entscheidung machen können damit
sie weniger Ängste und Unsicherheiten
haben diese verpflichtende Beratung
meine Damen und Herren ist ein milderes
Mittel im Vergleich zu einer Impfpflicht
denn eine Impfpflicht darf nur eine
ultima ratio sein und nicht eine
sofortige Umsetzung dieser Situation
wir wollen die Impflücken schließen vor
allem die impflücke der vulnerablen
Personen und das bis zum Herbst denn ein
Ziel sollte uns eigentlich einigen wir
müssen die vulnerable Menschen schützen
vor Krankenhausaufenthalte die wir
letztes Jahr vorletztes 19 und dieses
Gesetz würde ein Gesamtkonzept der
pandemiebekämpfung auch gut hineinpassen
unser Gesetzentwurf baut Brücken baut
Brücke mit den anderen Einträgen die wir
hier im Bundestag haben wir wollen und
da lade ich alle
Demokraten diesem Parlament auf
mitzuarbeiten dass wir eine Lösung für
unser Land bekommen dass wir Weihnachten
dieses Jahr mit unseren Lieben mit
unseren Freunden so feiern können wie
wir es gewohnt sind denn das haben wir
heute in der Hand wenn wir heute etwas
nicht ändern dann sind wir verloren und
haben wieder an Weihnachten wie wir es
letzten zwei Jahre erlebt haben und das
wollen wir eigentlich verhindern und
deshalb frage ich bitte ich um die
Zusammenarbeit dann spätere Zustimmung
zu diesem Gesetz herzliches Dankeschön
Andrew Ulmen war Ullmann war das
Entschuldigung der für seinen Antrag den
er gemeinsam mit einer ganzen Reihe
anderer Abgeordneten auch aus anderen
Fraktionen geworden hat also möglichst
viel intensive Beratung und erst wenn
die Impfquote zu niedrig ist auch eine
Impfpflicht ab 50 Jahren der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister steht schon
wenn es der nächste Redner in dieser
Debatte Robert Habeck und er spricht
auch für den Antrag den Gesetzentwurf
für eine generelle Impfpflicht
Impfpflicht ab 18 ich rede also für die
allgemeine Impfpflicht mit 18 und ich
will das auch gleich begründen zuvor
würde ich gerne eine Anmerkung machen
dass wir hier diskutieren und dass wir
uns für den Weg entschieden haben
gruppenanträge zu gehen den Weg der
gruppenanträge zu gehen entbindet uns
natürlich nicht von der Pflicht eine
Lösung zu finden am Ende wäre das
Schlimmste wenn es keine Lösung geben
wurde ja es ist eine moralisch komplexe
Abwägung die wir jetzt alle vornehmen
müssen aber ich will ausdrücklich sagen
die individuelle Gewissensentscheidung
kann nicht dazu führen dass wir der
Verantwortung zum Wohle der Menschen in
diesem Land am Ende nicht gerecht werden
es wurde sich eben kurz darüber
ausgetauscht ob man hätte eine Debatte
zu Ukraine oder nicht führen können
hätte man diese Debatte geführt hätte
man überhaupt Debatten über Krisen
geführt gäbe es ein Übergang zu dieser
Debatte nämlich die Frage und das ist
die Frage die beantwortet werden muss
tun wir alles um Vorsorge zu treffen die
vorsorgefrage ist die Frage wie wir mit
den Krisen umgehen und Vorsorge bedeutet
Denken in Eventualitäten was kann alles
noch passieren diese Frage nicht der
Status Quo nicht die ommikon-variante
steht im Mittelpunkt der Debatte sondern
tun wir alles dafür dieses Land und ihre
Menschen zu schützen vor wieder großen
freiheitseinschränkungen und wenn man
das wenn man das sich klar macht worum
es eigentlich geht dann muss man
feststellen erstens das Virus ist
typischer fieser und mutantenreicher als
wir es uns vor zwei oder drei Jahren
überhaupt haben träumen lassen zweitens
Menschen sind aus guten oder schlechten
Gründen widerwilliger sich zu schützen
vor diesem Virus und damit wo kriegen
wir nicht den Grundschutz in der
Gesellschaft
viertens die freiheitsabwägung bzw die
freiheitsinterpretation der wenigen darf
nicht zur permanenten
Freiheitseinschränkung der vielen führen
das kann nicht der Deal sein
wir stimmen also bei der Frage darüber
ab ob wir am Ende wieder ein ein Regime
einkehren wollen dass das kulturelle
liegen Leben zum Alarm bringt das Kinder
und Menschen die ist nicht zu dicke
haben in die Isolation zwingt das wieder
massive freiheitseinbußen und
Untersagung des öffentlichen Lebens bzw
gesellschaftlichen Lebens einkehrt das
müssen wir doch mal durchbrechen das
müssen wir doch verhindern darum geht es
doch im Kern
ich würde gerne an dieser Stelle sagen
wir haben es satt die Menschen in diesem
Land haben es satt bringen wir diese
Pandemie endlich hinter uns erledigen
wir das Virus und kehren wir dann zur
Freiheit zurück ja es wäre besser
gewesen Menschen hätten sich freiwillig
in großer Zahl impfen lassen das wäre
natürlich die bessere Lösung gewesen
aber das hier ist nicht getan haben
entbindet dieses Haus und uns alle nicht
von der Verantwortung dafür zu sorgen
dass wir wieder ein freies Leben in
Deutschland führen können und nicht über
den Einschränkungen leben deswegen
Stimmen die für ein Antrag der die
herdenimmunität in Deutschland hochhält
so dass wir wieder das Virus besiegen
können danke schön
Robert Habeck Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister und der
nächste Redner ist Tino Sorge aus der
Unionsfraktion wo er auch
gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher ist und
deswegen mutmaßen wir mal dass er für
den unionsantrag Antrag eintreten wird
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrter Herr Habeck sie
haben vollkommen recht wir hätten schon
viel viel früher hier über dieses Thema
in diesem Plenum debattieren müssen und
dass wir das eben nicht getan haben dass
wir nicht früher darüber debattiert
haben das lag an Bundeskanzler Scholz
das lag an Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach die noch Ende letzten Jahres
vollmundig bekundet haben sich sein für
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht haben aber
nicht die Kraft besessen hier in diesem
Hohen Haus ein kompromissfähigen Antrag
einzubringen genau das ist das Problem
und deshalb haben wir jetzt die
Situation wie wir sie haben sie haben
den Weg der gruppenanträge gewählt mit
unsicheren Mehrheiten sehr langsam und
Wissen letztendlich nicht wie die ganze
Sache ausgeht und wenn jetzt immer
argumentiert wird wir müssten doch jetzt
alle an einem Strang ziehen dann
erklären Sie doch mal wie dieser Strang
aussieht und wir haben als einzige
Fraktion hier gesagt die unterbreiten
einen Kompromissvorschlag wir sind fast
200 Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
Unionsfraktion und wir haben genau das
getan was die Aufgabe der Ampel gewesen
wäre nämlich ein Kompromissvorschlag für
dieses komplexe Thema zu unterbreiten
und deshalb höre ich immer in den
letzten Tagen es wäre ja schön wenn man
sich hier im Hohen Hauser einigen würde
wenn man einen Kompromiss finden würde
ich sage Ihnen ganz klar dieser
Kompromiss liegt seit Wochen auf dem
Tisch ist der impfvorsorgemechanismus
unserer Fraktion liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und deshalb kann ich Ihnen auch nur noch
mal sagen es geht hier bei diesem Thema
nicht um pauschale Lösung wir haben ein
sehr komplexes Problem wir haben
geänderte Rahmenbedingungen wir haben
mit der Omicron Variante höhere
Infektionszahlen aber viel viel mildere
Verläufe und deshalb wäre es völlig
falsch mit einer pauschalen Lösung wie
hier suggeriert wird also alle sollen
sich impfen lassen impf ist gut ja aber
alle Menschen zu zwingen sich impfen
lassen wird nicht dazu führen dass wir
das Problem lösen das liegt erstens
daran weil wir nicht differenzieren bei
dem Antrag impfpflich für alle deshalb
haben wir gesagt als Unionsfraktion wir
brauchen einen im vorsorgemechanismus
das heißt wir schauen uns an haben wir
überhaupt eine ordentliche
Datengrundlage genau das ist doch das
Kernproblem wir reden seit über zwei
Jahren darüber dass wir die Menschen zum
Impfen animieren wollen wir wissen gar
nicht wer geimpft ist und deshalb ist
die klare Forderung in diesem Antrag ein
impfregister damit die erstmal die
Datengrundlage haben um genau diese
Pandemie da bekämpfen zu können zweiter
Punkt
das bringt doch nichts jetzt zu sagen
alle sollen sich impfen lassen natürlich
helfen uns Impfung jeder kann
individuelle entscheiden Impfung führen
dazu dass ich keine schweren Verläufe
habe aber die Impfung mit den jetzigen
Impfstoffen gibt uns doch nicht die
Gewähr dafür dass wir im Herbst für eine
Variante die wir momentan überhaupt noch
nicht kennen mit einem Impfstoff den wir
momentan überhaupt noch nicht haben dass
wir damit aus dieser Dauerschleife
herauskommen und deshalb liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen geht es um
Differenzierung und genau das tut unser
Antrag denn unser Antrag
nimmt auch die notwendige
Differenzierung vor liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir sagen erstens wir
brauchen die impfinfrastruktur die wird
vorgehalten wenn sich die Lage
verschlechtert heißt dass wir können es
schnell wieder hochfahren gleichzeitig
sagen die aber auch wir müssen
wissenschaftlich evaluiert
wissenschaftlich determiniert sagen
können welche Gruppen betrifft es wer
hat ein hohes Risiko können wir diese
Gruppen damit schützen schützen haben
wir ein eigenes Mittel und als letzten
Punkt dieses Mittel muss verhältnismäßig
sein und nicht Verhältnismäßigkeit ist
nur dann gegeben wenn wir damit auch das
Ziel was Sie erreichen wollen nämlich
Schutz der Bevölkerung erreichen können
und deshalb ich komme zum Schluss frau
Präsidentin stimmen Sie unseren
impfvorsorgemechanismus zu das ist der
einzige sinnvolle Kompromiss und
gangbarer Weg und tun Sie das nicht
wieder Minister immer ab mit
Parteipolitik weil wenn das
Parteipolitik ist dass wir als
Opposition Vorschläge unterbreiten oder
die Regierung kritisieren
ich das als Kompliment
sie können das gerne als Kompliment
empfinden aber nicht meine Ermahnung das
nehme ich nicht an weil wir haben ja
alle nur sehr kurze Redezeiten in dieser
Debatte und deswegen kann ich nicht
jetzt locker sagen sie dürfen 50 Minuten
50 Sekunden Minuten überziehen
ich bin am Ende dank am Ende mit meiner
Rede danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
jetzt hat
ja das ist vielleicht auch noch mal ein
wichtiger Hinweis auch für Sie die diese
Debatte verfolgen vier Minuten das ist
die längste Redezeit die hier eingeräumt
wird in der Debatte geht beispielsweise
für den Bremer Bürgermeister Andreas
bovenschulte der nachher noch kommt die
allermeisten haben drei manchmal auch
nur zwei Minuten Martin sichert aus der
afd-fraktion hat drei Damen und Herren
weil meine Tochter Kontakt mit einem
positiv getesteten Kind hatte forderte
mich das Gesundheitsamt auf ich solle
Zitat möglichst innerhalb des Haushalts
getrennte Räume nutzen und gemeinsame
Mahlzeiten vermeiden bei einer
zweijährigen das meine Damen und Herren
ist staatliche Aufforderung zur
Kindesmisshandlung
so weit so weit konnte es nur kommen
weil man die Maßnahmen von der Realität
von Daten Fakten und echtem
Gesundheitsschutz völlig entkoppelt hat
laut Daten der Betriebskrankenkassen gab
es bis August mehr
Arbeitsunfähigkeitstage wegen
Impfnebenwirkungen als nach einem
positiven corona-test mehr
Arbeitsunfähigkeit wegen
Impfnebenwirkungen als nach positivem
corona-test diese Impfung meine Damen
und Herren ist eindeutig nicht sicher
der Kölner Karneval bei 2g+ war ein
superspredder Event das beweist dass die
Impfung keinen ausreichenden fremdschutz
bietet auch der Eigenschutz funktioniert
nicht es sind mehr
corona-intensivpatienten gebustert als
ungeimpft eine Impfpflicht ohne
ausreichende Sicherheit oder Wirksamkeit
des Impfstoffes ist nur eines eindeutig
verfassungswidrig
auch gesundheitspolitisch gibt es keine
Grundlage für eine Impfpflicht in den
letzten beiden Jahren waren jeweils
zweieinhalb Millionen Patienten weniger
in den Krankenhäusern als 2019 auch auf
den Intensivstationen liegen seit
Monaten deutlich weniger Menschen als im
Durchschnitt
18.091 waren es letzten Sonntag das ist
der niedrigste jemals gemessene Wert an
Intensivpatienten eine Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems drohte nie zu jedem
Zeitpunkt in den letzten zwei Jahren
waren tausende Intensivbetten verfügbar
was aber fehlt sind wichtige Studien zur
Impfung man gibt Erbgut des Virus in den
menschlichen Körper und weiß bis heute
nicht was danach passiert wie verhält
sich der Impfstoff genau im Körper wie
verteilt er sich in welchen Organen
welche Auswirkungen hat die mRNA noch
neben das Bike Proteinproduktion welche
Schäden können durch das bikeprotein
passieren fragen über Fragen die niemand
beantworten kann weil das nicht
ausreichend erforscht ist
meine Damen und Herren real Satire ist
wenn alle Bundestagspräsidenten geimpft
sind vier von sechs an Corona erkrankt
sind und der Bundestag trotz dieser
offensichtlichen Unwirksamkeit über eine
Impfpflicht diskutiert
die anderen Länder haben begriffen dass
Maßnahmen mehr Schaden als Nutzen Nein
zur Impfpflicht Nein zur Corona Willkür
beenden wir es endlich auch in
Deutschland vielen Dank
und zu Ende ist auch die Redezeit von
Martin Sicherheit aus der afd-fraktion
Tabea Rösner wird die nächste Rednerin
sein aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
und sie ist gegen eine Impfpflicht
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
uns eint das Ziel die Pandemie zu
bewältigen und die Überlastung des
Gesundheitswesens abzuwenden ein guter
Immunstatus trägt wesentlich dazu bei
und eins sind wir uns ob eine
Impfpflicht das geeignete Instrument ist
diese Differenz zieht sich durch die
Gesellschaft durch familienwissenschaft
und Parteien selten wurde so emotional
diskutiert die Menschen gerade die
jungen sehnen sich nach Normalität und
das ist nur verständlich
uns haben viele Menschen auch zahlreiche
geimpfte geschrieben dass sie eine
Impfentscheidung selbst treffen wollen
viele haben
Ängste einige berichten von starken
Impfreaktionen dem paul Ehrlich Institut
liegen nur gemeldete Nebenwirkungen und
im Schäden vor wie hoch die Dunkelziffer
ist wissen wir nicht wir sollten die
Fälle systematisch erfassen damit nehmen
wir die Bedenken ernst und das schafft
auch vertrauen
hat die Lage grundlegend verändert wir
wissen nicht welchen Schutz die Impfung
bei neuen Varianten bietet und eine
sterile Immunität so führen die
Virologen kann mit einer Impfpflicht
nicht erreicht werden wenn ich mir aber
die reden hier anhöre fürchte ich dass
genau diese Erwartung geweckt wird und
das führt doch zu weiterem Frust nach
heutigem Stand
geht es bei der Impfung eher um den
eigen als um den fremdschutz und daher
ist eine Impfpflicht noch schwieriger zu
rechtfertigen und die Aufgabe die
Aufgabe des Staates ist nicht die
Menschen vor sich selbst zu schützen
sondern das Gesundheitssystem am Laufen
zu halten
wir brauchen niedrigschwellige
Beratungsangebote mehr Forschung eine
bessere Datenlage und ein wirksamer
anhaltender Immunstatus nach einer
durchgemachten Infektion sollte
angesichts des erheblichen
Grundrechtseingriffs anerkannt werden
[Applaus]
bei der beantworten bei der Beurteilung
der Immunität der Bevölkerung sollte
auch die Zahl der durch eine Infektion
immunisierten Menschen berücksichtigt
werden jetzt ist die Redezeit brauchen
weniger Alarmismus und mehr Sachlichkeit
neue Erkenntnisse führen in der
Wissenschaft dazu Positionen zu
revidieren daran sollten wir uns in der
Politik ein Beispiel nehmen vielen
Tabea Rösner aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen mit einem Plädoyer gegen eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht oder überhaupt
gegen eine Impfpflicht sind immer
sozusagen
nicht so streng aber streng
dr paula hat jetzt das Wort für die
Gruppe janitschek Ullmann und andere
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin und
erstmal herzlichen Dank dass Sie mit
Petra Pau hier diese Woche diesen
wahnsinnsjob machen allein zu zweit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Impfpflicht ist offensichtlich nicht
mehr das wichtigste Thema in diesem Haus
das sieht man auch hier gerade gut aber
ich glaube sie kann unglaublich
wichtiger Baustein sein und Hinweisgeber
bei der Frage ob wir die vielen
verschiedenen Krisen die wir jetzt
gerade alle gemeinsam lösen müssen ob
wir der dieser Verantwortung als dieses
Haus wirklich gerecht werden und ich
verstehe sehr gut dass viele bei dieser
Frage keinen Kompromiss machen wollen
aber gerade vor dem Hintergrund der
vielen Krisen die wir jetzt alle auf
einmal bewältigen müssen dürfen
Kompromisse nicht schlecht geredet
werden und ich verstehe jeden der Gruppe
über 18 ich verstehe jeden der das
Gefühl hat hier könnte sich eventuell am
Ende nicht die beste Variante
durchsetzen
aber ich möchte darum bitten dann
trotzdem nicht alles beiseite zu wischen
was man auch mit einer Teillösung noch
erreichen kann gerade für die Pflege
jeder der sich immer aufgeregt hat
darüber dass für die Pflege nur vom
Balkon geklatscht wurde der kann jetzt
hier über seinen eigenen Schatten
springen und zumindest erreichen dass
die Überlassung des Gesundheitswesens
und damit die Überlastung der vielen
Menschen die in diesen Gesundheitswesen
arbeiten und gerade jeden Monat
Kolleginnen und Kollegen verlieren das
zumindest der vorgebeugt wird
und ich glaube am Ende wird sich auch
hier entscheiden ob wir dieser
Verantwortung gerecht werden die jetzt
auf unseren Schultern liegt und ich habe
heute nicht in jeder Minute in diesem
Haus das Gefühl gehabt dass dieser
Bundestag sich gerade seiner
Verantwortung bewusst ist aber wenn wir
gut sind wenn wir richtig gut sind dann
werden wir auch am Ende dieses Prozesses
zeigen dass auch wenn es schwierig ist
dass auch wenn es kompliziert ist auch
wenn viele Menschen gerade auch jüngere
Menschen bei uns sehr mit sich Ringen
und die aktuell auf dem Tisch liegenden
Kompromisslösung nicht gut finden dass
wir es trotzdem schaffen am Ende hier
eine Mehrheit dafür zu haben die
Lebensbedingungen in diesem Land und die
Möglichkeit für alle Patienten gerade
auch die vielen Menschen die jetzt
gerade neu zu uns kommen im Herbst in
einem gut funktionierenden
Gesundheitssystem zu erhalten vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
Katrin Henning klar spricht jetzt für
die Gruppe Behrens und anderen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren was ist unsere Aufgabe
als Politik ich bin aus tiefstem Herzen
liberale also lautet meine Antwort zu
tun was notwendig ist und zu unterlassen
was nicht unbedingt notwendig ist
andersherum Politik muss sich wann immer
möglich heraushalten und Menschen ihr
Leben selbstbestimmt führen lassen
gerade deswegen streite ich für die
allgemeine Impfpflicht
es ist richtig
freiheitseinschränkungen jetzt zurück zu
fahren und gleichzeitig die
Erwartungshaltung zu kommunizieren dass
jeder sofern noch nicht geschehen bis
zum Herbst einen vollständigen
Impfschutz erwirbt ich möchte nicht nur
dass wir so schnell wie möglich
Beschränkungen zurücknehmen können ich
möchte dass wir sie nicht jeden Herbst
neu einführen müssen dass wir in Zukunft
überhaupt nicht mehr in diese Maßnahmen
Spirale
freiheit ist nicht nur Freiheit vor
Spritzen Freiheit ist auch in Schule und
Kita zu lernen und zu spielen Freiheit
ist auch die Freiheit für Selbstständige
und Unternehmer für Weihnachtsmärkte
schicker und boutiquebesitzer
Theaterschauspieler und Messebauer ihren
Beruf nachgehen zu können
Freiheit bedeutet sich bei Indikation
einer Krankenhausbehandlung unterziehen
zu können und nicht auf das Abflachen
der aktuellen corona-welle warten zu
müssen
Freiheit ist auch im Alter mit der
Familie im Pflegeheim Geburtstag feiern
zu dürfen meine Damen und Herren auf dem
Rücken all dieser Menschen wird die viel
zu geringe Impfquote in Deutschland
ausgetragen all diesen Menschen
gegenüber besteht auch eine
Schutzpflicht des Staates
Grundrechte sind Abwehrrechte gegenüber
dem Staat sie sollen den Staat zwingen
sich zu rechtfertigen wenn er in die von
ihnen geschützten Rechtsgüter eingreift
sie sollen ihn nicht zur Untätigkeit
verdammen um bei einer aktuellen
coronawelle kurzfristig eine Überlastung
des Gesundheitssystems entgegenzuwirken
haben wir inzwischen ein Instrumentarium
entwickelt aber die Anwendung dieser
Instrumente hinterlässt massive
Kollateralschäden lassen Sie uns das so
gut es geht vermeiden gehen wir mit
einer umfassenden Pflichtigen
Impfkampagne einen anderen Weg denken
wir weiter denn auch das Virus mutiert
weiter wir haben ein Konzept vorgelegt
dass noch einmal auf umfassende
Informationen setzt am Ende aber auch
eine klare Erwartung kommuniziert wir
schlagen eine Umsetzung vor die für die
allermeisten ganz unkompliziert
erfüllbar ist mit einem einfachen Upload
oder einem Gang in die Apotheke machen
wir das und ja es gibt das Risiko dass
wir die Impfpflicht am Ende nicht
gebraucht haben werden dagegen abzuwägen
ist das Risiko dass wir uns alle und
unsere Kinder erneut stark zurücknehmen
müssen für mich ist das Ergebnis der
Abwägung klar vielen Dank
und das war Kathrin Helling klar aus der
FDP-Fraktion die sich ausgesprochen hat
für den Entwurf für den Gesetzentwurf
der hier unter Gruppe bährens läuft also
für eine Impfpflicht ab 18 also wir
sehen in der SPD bei den Grünen auch bei
der FDP es gibt es unterschiedliche
Auffassungen die gibt es möglicherweise
auch in der Unionsfraktion aber da ist
man noch recht geschlossen was die
Auftritte in dieser Debatte hier angeht
und ich vermute das wird jetzt auch so
sein bei Andrea Lindholz der
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
mir fällt es immer noch schwer an dieser
Stelle zur Impfpflicht zu sprechen ich
stehe immer noch unter den Eindrücken
der Rede des ukrainischen Präsidenten
und ich will an dieser Stelle nur eines
sagen bevor ich zum eigentlichen Thema
gekommen es wäre anständig gewesen es
wäre angemessen gewesen es wäre
erforderlich gewesen dass die Fraktionen
in diesem Bundestag die Möglichkeit
gehabt hätten unmittelbar auf diese Rede
zu antworten und ihre Solidarität zu
bekunden und das war keine glanzstunde
was dieses Parlament hier heute morgen
abgeleistet hat
[Applaus]
wir beraten in dieser Woche zu dem
wichtigen Thema der Pandemie zwei
Vorhaben
sie liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Ampel wollen morgen in der zweiten
Lesung
die maskenpflicht im Rahmen des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes quasi
abschaffen die verpflichtende
maskenpflicht im öffentlichen Raum zu
einer Zeit in der die Inzidenz bei 1.651
liegt zu einer Zeit in der die
corona-fälle täglich bei knapp 300.000
liegen und die Todesfälle über 200
betragen sie wollen die maskenpflicht
abschaffen und sie tun das morgen mit
ihrer Mehrheit wir werden ausdrücklich
nicht zustimmen die Maske schützt direkt
und unmittelbar denjenigen der sie trägt
und das Gegenüber die maskenpflicht ist
kein großer Eingriff in die Grundrechte
die maskenpflicht ist das mildeste und
geeignetste Mittel um der jetzigen
Situation Schutz vor dem Coronavirus zu
bieten gerade auch wohl in der rablen
Personen ich will ihnen sagen wenn Sie
eine Person mit einer im Kirche sind
weil sie eine schwere Erkrankung haben
und Sie müssen einkaufen gehen sie
müssen nicht ins Restaurant gehen aber
Sie müssen einkaufen gehen und sie
versuchen täglich zu verhindern dass Sie
sich anstecken dann sind sie demnächst
schutzlos sie können selber freiwillig
noch eine Maske tragen aber ob das
Gegenüber eine Maske trägt bleibt ihrem
Gegenüber freiwillig überlassen und ich
finde das zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
verantwortungslos natürlich muss man
auch über die Reduzierung der
maskenpflicht sprechen aber doch bitte
zu einem Zeitpunkt der angemessen und
richtig ist ich kann es beim besten
Willen nicht nachvollziehen was sie sich
hier überlegt haben und die gleichen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die morgen der
Abschaffung der maskenpflicht der
verpflichtenden maskenpflicht zustimmen
werden sprechen sich hier in großen
Teilen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt für eine
sofortige
das Licht aus es tut mir wirklich leid
es ist wirklich Chaos was bei ihnen in
der Gesundheitspolitik herrscht
wir wissen bei der Impfung dass sie für
den Herbst als Vorbereitung wichtig ist
das heißt unser Antrag sieht ganz klar
vor die Impfkampagne weiterzufahren wir
wollen auch vorbereitet sein für den
Herbst deswegen sagen mit unserem
impfvorsorgeantrag auch ganz klar bitte
führen Sie endlich das zwingend
notwendige Register ein wir brauchen den
Überblick über den Status wir müssen
Personen gezielt ansprechen können auch
was boosterimpfungen angeht wir müssen
die ungeimpften noch mal gezielt
ansprechen können und wir müssen mit
einer validen Datenlage endlich die
Pandemie vernünftig steuern können in
dieser Lage jetzt und zum dritten
haben wir mit unserem Antrag einen
Mechanismus vorgesehen der dann wenn es
nötig und erforderlich ist einen
stufenweisen impfmechanismus in Gang
setzt und dafür müssen sie jetzt
sozusagen in einem Monitoring die
Infektionszahlen der über 60-Jährigen
beachten den R-Wert und die Situation
auf den Intensivstationen
können wir
auch nicht agieren und deswegen bitte
ich Sie auch unserem wirklich guten
vernünftigen Antrag zuzustimmen und
daraus ein gutes Gesetz zu machen das
wäre die richtige Vorsorge für den
Herbst Frau Kollegin was kommt und ich
bitte Sie auch morgen nicht der Änderung
Andrea Lindholz wird da noch mal schnell
erwarten ermahnt von der
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin der Bundestag
diskutiert über die Impfpflicht und da
lohnt ein Blick auf die Impfquote im
Moment bundesweit mindestens einmal
geimpft derzeit
76,5% der Bevölkerung
grundimmunisiert also mit zwei Impfungen
75,8% und Personen mit Auffrischimpfung
58%, das ist angesichts von Omicron und
weiteren Varianten zu wenig sagen Leute
die sich mit dem Thema auskennen und
jetzt gibt es noch eine Ermahnung für
die die hier ihre Maske nicht korrekt
tragen und das haben sie im Laufe der
Debatte schon gesehen in welcher
Fraktion das vor allem so gehandhabt
wird Zwischenrufen oder Gesprächen mit
der Nachbarin oder dem Nachbarn ich
bitte Sie das zu berücksichtigen ich
habe gestern hier schon damit drohen
müssen dass es Ordnungsmaßnahmen gibt
und jetzt gebe ich das dem Kollegen Dr
Andreas bovenschulte dem Bürgermeister
von Bremen für die Gruppe Behrens wir
haben das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und herrenabgeordnete im
Land Bremen sind ca 90 Prozent der
Menschen einmal geimpft die Zahl der
doppelt geimpften Licht etwas darunter
und fast zwei Drittel sind auch schon
gebustert und ich muss sagen
ich muss sagen wir sind auch ein
bisschen stolz auf diese zahlenden sie
sind das Ergebnis einer großen
gesamtgesellschaftlichen
Kraftanstrengung von Politik und
Verwaltung von Hilfsorganisationen und
heimischer Wirtschaft wir haben
leistungsfähige Impfzentren aufgebaut
wir sind mit unseren impftrucks in die
Quartiere gefahren wir haben dezentrale
Angebote in unseren Bürgerhäusern
gemacht wir haben mehrsprachige
gesundheitsfachkräfte in die Quartiere
geschickt wo die Impfquoten besonders
niedrig sind wir haben geworben wir
haben diskutiert wir haben auch
gestritten und wir haben es dadurch
durch die Ansprache der gesamten
Bevölkerung geschafft ein richtig gutes
impfklima im Land zu schaffen mit
Argumenten ohne Druck und ohne Zwang
und trotzdem meine Damen und Herren
spreche ich mich heute für die
Einführung einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht
in Deutschland aus eine Position
übrigens die ich hier nicht alleine
vertrete sondern stellvertretend für die
16 Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidentin die sich schon
mehrfach auf ihren Konferenzen ganz klar
und eindeutig hinter dieser Forderung
versammelt haben
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
wenn jetzt die Impfquote bundesweit
stagniert obwohl ausreichend Impfstoffe
jederzeit verfügbar sind und wo es
ausreichend Informationen zum Impfen in
allen möglichen Sprachen gibt dann
stellt sich schon die Frage welche
Schlüsse müssen wir daraus ziehen eine
Erkenntnis ist aus meiner Sicht zentral
die meisten die sich bisher nicht haben
impfen lassen werden diesen Schritt ohne
eine gesetzliche Impfpflicht auch
künftig nicht gehen das könnten wir
jetzt natürlich einfach hinnehmen als
Ausdruck individueller
freiheitsbetätigung wirklich klug meine
Damen und Herren wer das aber nicht denn
die meisten dieser Menschen werden sich
über kurz oder lang infizieren etliche
werden mangels Impfung schwer erkranken
müssen in den Krankenhäusern und auf den
Intensivstationen behandelt werden und
spätestens dann wenn die Kliniken an
ihre Belastungsgrenzen stoßen sollten
wäre das für uns alle ein Problem dann
wäre das nicht mehr Ausdruck
individueller freiheitsbetätigung
sondern ein tiefes grundlegendes
gesellschaftliches Problem dann müssten
wir reagieren dann drohten wieder
Beschränkungen teil-lockdowns dann
drohten wieder Schließungen von
Geschäften Schulen und Kitas dann
drohten wieder kontaktbeschränkungen
ökonomischen und nicht zuletzt die
sozialen Folgen immer wiederkehrender
beschränkungszyklen sind enorm als
Bürgermeister habe ich in den
vergangenen Wochen und Monaten viele
Gespräche mit Eltern und Schülerinnen
und Schülern mit Unternehmern mit
Vertretern von Sportvereinen von Kirchen
von Verbänden geführt und ich kann ihnen
einst versichern die Menschen wollen und
können nicht mehr ich kann jedem nur
dringend empfehlen sich einmal mit einer
alleinerziehenden berufstätigen Mutter
zu unterhalten und darüber zu sprechen
was monatelange Schul- und
kita-schließung mit ihr gemacht haben
meine Damen und Herren die Familien in
Deutschland sind wirklich am Limit
muss deshalb
ganz klar und deutlich zu sagen wenn wir
die Pandemie ohne Impfpflicht hinter uns
lassen könnten das wäre gut das wäre
schön wenn wir aber nur die Wahl haben
zwischen einer ständigen beschränkungs-
und Lockdown Gefahr und der Impfpflicht
dann sollten wir uns für die Impfpflicht
entscheiden
meine Damen und Herren ich habe es ein
Land gesagt im Kreis der
Ministerpräsident und
Ministerpräsidenten haben wir uns
mehrfach einmütig hinter der allgemeinen
Impfpflicht versammelt zuletzt vor vier
Wochen insbesondere die Kollegen von der
Union weil stets ein großes Anliegen
eine entsprechende Forderung in die
mpk-beschlüsse aufzunehmen deshalb hoffe
ich sehr dass am Ende auch die
Abgeordnete der Union eine allgemeine
gesetzlichen Impfpflicht zustimmen
werden herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Andreas
der sich hier für eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht ausgesprochen hat und jetzt
gibt es auch einen Redner aus der
linksfraktionen Gregor Gysi schreit
und auch diese Informationen noch mal
Gregor Gysi wird mal gerade eine einzige
Minute Redezeit haben nicht mehr möglich
ja vielleicht bin ich auch so streng
weil wir bis heute Nacht hier zu zweit
sitzen aber nehmen Sie es dann als
persönliche Betroffenheit das können sie
gerne genau
das macht aber nichts jetzt habe ich
nämlich
dem Kollegen Dr Gregor Gysi das Wort zu
geben für die Gruppe Kubicki und für
eine Minute
frau Präsidentin meine kürzester Rede in
der Geschichte des Bundestages ich bin
dreimal geimpft und genesen mehr geht
gar nicht aber ich bin ein strikter
Gegner der allgemeinen Impfpflicht bei
Masern war ich dafür weil
dass die Krankheit ausrottete das
schafft der Impfstoff hier nicht
eigentlich brauchen wir eine Aufklärung
30 pro Tag und Bremen hat es ja
geschafft auch dank unserer Linken
Sozialsenatorin Geldbußen sind für mich
der falsche Weg und wenn sie regeln ist
die dürfen nicht umgewandelt werden in
Haftstrafen dann werden die anderen die
bei denen umgewandelt wird wegen der
Geldbußen von Bundesverfassungsgericht
ziehen viel Spaß wegen der Gleichheit
von dem Gesetz den Wunsch nach einer
Zwischenfrage möchten Sie das Zulassen
Herr gießen
[Applaus]
ich weiß jetzt nicht was sie dafür
bezahlt haben
ja gerne Herr Kollege bitte die
Zwischenfrage ist zugelassen ich hoffe
dass jetzt keine marktwirtschaftliche
Angelegenheit
unterbringen kann
ja vielen Dank Herr Kollege Gysi dass
sie diese Zwischenfrage zulassen und ich
bin überzeugt dass sie die letzten
Sekunden auch noch hinbekommen werden
meine Frage an Sie konkret ist was ist
ihre Lösung die Krankheitslast für den
kommenden Winter den durchaus
hypothetischer passieren könnte
eigentlich begegnen wollen weil das ist
ja keine Lösung wir wollen nicht impfen
oder wir wollen keine Impfpflicht
einführen wie wollen sie die restliche
diese impflücke eigentlich schließen die
ist ja das sehe ich nicht momentan in
ihrer Lösung ja ich sagte gerade ich
sagte gerade dass wir 30.000 Menschen
pro Tag überzeugen müssen und ich finde
das kann uns gelingen wenn wir so machen
wie es in Bremen gemacht worden ist wenn
wir das überall so machen und
außerdem will ich noch sagen wir haben
jetzt 16 Millionen nicht geimpfte mal
angenommen fünf Millionen machten das
nach der Pflicht dann bleiben 11
Millionen übrig wie viel hunderttausende
Ordnungsämter brauchen wir dann
eigentlich um das durchzusetzen ein
Gesetz dass man nicht durchsetzen kann
darf man auch nicht beschließen danke
schön
[Applaus]
Katrin Vogler spricht jetzt zu uns für
die Gruppe Behrens und andere
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen lieber
Gregor Gysi ich schätze dich als Mensch
und Politiker weil die liegst du einfach
falsch
inzwischen dürfte doch in Deutschland
fast jeder jemanden kennen die oder der
gerade wegen corvid 19 krank oder in
Quarantäne ist wir haben aktuell eine
Inzidenz fast dreimal so hoch in wie ein
vergleichbaren Ländern täglich mehr als
200 Tote zunehmende
Krankenhauseinweisung und auch wieder
mehr Menschen und zwar vor allem
ungeimpfte auf den Intensivstationen
auch von unseren Kolleginnen sind einige
die heute mitdiskutieren wollten wegen
Corvette 19 nicht bei uns und ich
wünsche Ihnen glaube in ihrer aller
Namen dass sie sie dass sie schnell und
vor allem vollständig gelesen
aber
selbstverständlich ist das nicht immer
mehr Menschen leiden langfristig und das
schweren Folgen selbst wenn die
Infektion leicht verlaufen ist die
Autorin Margarete Stokowski beschreibt
ihre Erfahrungen mit long corvid in
ihrer jüngsten spiegelkolonne Kolumne
eine Kolumne die sie ansonsten einfach
mal so leicht runter schrieb die er
jetzt aber alle Kraft und viel Zeit
abverlangt
falls es Sie interessiert ich habe jetzt
seit zwei Monaten täglich Kopfschmerzen
und bin von jeder Kleinigkeit erschöpft
ich habe immer wieder Schwächeanfälle
für mehrere Stunden und dazu ein
fiebriges Kribbeln Null Hunger oder
Appetit mein Gehirn funktioniert nicht
richtig und ich schlafe oft 14 Stunden
und bin danach absolut nicht erholt
sondern genauso kaputt wie am Tag davor
meine Damen und Herren von longkorbit
kann man sich nicht individuell Schützen
der beste Schutz davor ist eine hohe
Impfquote in der Bevölkerung neben
maskenabstand und all den Maßnahmen die
wir kennen weil geimpfte einfach weniger
ansteckend sind
und es gibt auch einen messbaren
Zusammenhang zwischen der Impfquote und
der Sterblichkeit und dennoch haben wir
es nicht überall geschafft so wie in
Bremen die Impflücken zu schließen und
jeder der glaubt dass wir das bis zum
Sommer schaffen weil wenn dann die
Infektionszahlen sinken und es keine
2g-regeln mehr gibt der glaubt auch noch
an die Zahnfee es gehörte einfach zur
menschlichen Natur gefahren die nicht
akut erscheinen zu verdrängen und und
erst dann zu handeln wenn sie wirklich
ein im persönlichen Umfeld auftauchen
aber wenn im Herbst dieses Jahres die
nächste corona-welle anrollt wer weiß
mit welchem Virus dann wird es zu spät
sein wenn wir dann nicht über lockdowns
kontaktbeschränkungen oder
Schulschließungen reden wollen dann
müssen wir jetzt handeln
und
nein die Idee Menschen per Gesetz zum
Impfen zu verpflichten die begeistert
mich überhaupt nicht und ich habe viel
Kritik an einer Politik die es überhaupt
erst so weit hat kommen lassen aber nach
zwei Jahren mit immer wiederholten
freiheitseinschränkungen und all ihren
sozialen und gesellschaftlichen
Verwüstungen die sie hinterlassen haben
dann halte ich das zumindest für
zumutbar alle Erwachsenen zu
verpflichten sich zum Schutz aller vor
dieser Krankheit unverwalteren
freiheitseinschränkungen zu impfen zu
lassen
Frau Kollegin kommen Sie zum Ende mein
besonderer Appell geht an dieser Stelle
an die Mitglieder der Unionsfraktion
verweigern sie sich nicht nutzen Sie die
Uneinigkeit der Regierungskoalition in
dieser Frage nicht für kurzfristige
Parteipolitik Frau Kolleginnen zeigen
sie Mut zur Verantwortung
Katrin Vogler aus der Linksfraktion und
wir sehen auch in der Linksfraktion gibt
es unterschiedliche Auffassungen was
eine Impfpflicht angeht ob ja oder in
der Version sogenannte Gruppe Behrens
hier vorgeschlagen hat nämlich eine
allgemeine ab 18 monolithische Blöcke in
dieser Debatte zumindest bislang
erkennbar lediglich in der
Unionsfraktion und in der AFD der
nächste Redner ist
Herbert Wollmann und er ist für den
Antrag von Andrew Uhlmann und anderer
abweichend vom Rede Skript eins
vorausschicken was ich gestern und
vorgestern und heute an medizinischen
Unsinn gehört habe das ist hanebüchen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren als arzt
für innere Medizin der in den letzten 30
Jahren in der Altmark ambulant und Stadt
und stationär praktiziert hat werde ich
zwei Dinge in meiner Rede deutlich
machen
erstens was hat mich dazu gebracht
diesen Ü50 Antrag mit einzubringen und
zweitens warum glaube ich dass es der
richtige Weg ist um aus der aktuellen
Situation hinauszukommen mir bleibt der
14 Januar 2021 in besonderer Erinnerung
an diesem von vielen Menschen in meinem
Wahlkreis herbeigesehnten Tag habe ich
erstmals mit meinem Praxisteam gegen
covid 19 geimpft der Dezember davor also
der dezember 2020
mit vielen Corona schwerkranken und
toten auch unter meinen Patienten und
Patientinnen war noch sehr
präsent und beeindruckend
eine weitere grenzwertige Belastung
unseres Gesundheitssystems darf es nicht
mehr gehen
impfen bleibt das beste Mittel
der das bisher nicht begriffen hat
handelt verantwortungslos
wir wissen zuverlässig das erstens eine
Impfung die Häufigkeit eine schweren
Verlaufes signifikant reduziert zweitens
dass die Nebenwirkungen der Impfungen
vergleichbar mit denen anderer Impfungen
sind und da muss ich der Abgeordnete
grünen weitgehend widersprechen die hier
von geredet hat das war wirklich daneben
zweitens
das ist eine altersabhängige Häufung von
schweren 19erkrankungen gibt die
insbesondere ab dem 50 Lebensjahr
zunehmend relevant wird und das ist ja
auch der Grund für unseren Antrag
besonders der dritte Punkt also die
Altersabhängigkeit der Komplikationen
führt in der Pandemie zu einer starken
Belastung unseres Gesundheitssystems
daher heißt es bei uns erst beraten erst
noch mal alle beraten dann impfen ja
Kollege
auch bei der ersten Rede wenn es dann
sehr viel ist ich erinnere Sie nur daran
dass ihre Redezeit um ist ich bin in
zehn Sekunden fertig gut
dieser Einschätzung die wir haben teilen
in ihrer Stellungnahme auch die
Mitglieder des Deutschen Ethikrates
an denen sich unser Antrag weitgehend
orientiert die Wahrung der
Verhältnismäßigkeit verpflichtet uns das
mildeste Mittel zu wählen
betrachtet man diese Aspekte so ist
dieser Gruppenantrag für 50 die beste
Lösung denn die Jüngeren sind nicht die
die unser Gesundheitssystem belasten
jetzt bin ich fertig und ich hoffe dass
wir unseren Antrag weitgehend zustimmen
danke und das war Herbert Wollmann aus
der SPD-Fraktion Facharzt und Oberarzt
in seinem bisherigen Leben ist er
gewesen das war seine erste Rede und
sein erster Satz war selten so viel
Unfug über das Impfen gehört wie heute
die nächste Rednerin für die Gruppe
Behrens Wiese und andere also für eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht ab 18 ist Emilia
fester aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
als die Pandemie begonnen hat war ich 21
Jahre alt
wissen Sie noch was sie gemacht haben
als sie 21 waren
ich habe aus dem ich habe innerhalb der
vergangenen zwei Jahre aus Vorsicht und
aus Rücksicht das folgende nicht gemacht
ich war nicht in der Uni
ich war nicht im Ausland
ich habe kein Museum und auch kein
Festival besucht ich habe nicht mal eine
Person die ich noch nicht kannte geküsst
oder meinen Geburtstag gefeiert
ich war verdammt noch meine ich einmal
im Club tanzen feiern und all das was
ich so vermisse das mag ihn jetzt
vielleicht lächerlich vorkommen aber
wissen Sie was wirklich lächerlich ist
wenn sie und ihre Freundinnen der
Freiheit sich einfach hätten impfen
lassen als die meisten von uns so
vernünftig waren und diesen einfachen
Schritt gegangen sind dann dann wäre ich
jetzt wieder frei
dann werden wir alle wieder frei oder
zumindest na ja um das zu machen was wir
lieben und worauf wir jetzt seit zwei
Jahren warten was manche von uns
depressiv macht Menschen in die
Einsamkeit stürzt und Familien in den
Wahnsinn treibt weil wir bereit sind
unsere Freiheit für das Leben anderer
Menschen zu geben vulnerable Gruppen zu
schützen das war und das ist unsere
Solidarität
aber
ich fordere jetzt den Payback wir haben
nämlich was gefunden was uns schützen
kann und deshalb bin ich meine Freiheit
zurück ich will sie zurück
und ich will sie nicht nur kurzzeitig
zurück weil jetzt einige Leute besonders
laut Freedom Day rufen
und offensichtlich alle Erfahrungen mit
diesem Virus die wir alle gemeinsam
gemacht haben
ignorieren Liebe FDP-Fraktion nur weil
man die Pandemie für beendet erklärt ist
sie noch nicht vorbei
ihre Ihre individuelle Freiheit Ende
dort wo meine beginnt wo die kollektive
Freiheit beginnt und ihre persönliche
Entscheidung sich nicht impfen zu lassen
beeinflusst mein Leben beeinflusst das
Leben von Millionen von Menschen in
dieser Bundesrepublik nicht die
Impfpflicht ist die Zumutung sondern
keine Impfpflicht ist die Zumutung die
Zumutung für die solidarische Mehrheit
ich habe mich nicht um ein
Bundestagsmandat beworben um im
Bundestag dabei zuzusehen wie meine
Generation in Klimafragen Angst um ihre
Zukunft haben muss und parallel dazu in
der Pandemie auch noch ihre Gegenwart
verliert ihre Freunde ihren Sport ihre
Bildung ihre Reisen ihren Spaß am jung
sein das muss jetzt ein Ende haben und
ich sage das jetzt auch noch mal ganz
deutlich es muss hier um die Impfpflicht
für alle Erwachsenen gehen nicht ab
irgendeiner willkürlichen Altersgrenze
denn alle Menschen egal welchen Alters
übertragen das Virus stärker wenn sie
ungeimpft sind es reicht nicht mehr mit
kosmetischen Eingriffen die schweren
Verläufe zu drücken wir arbeiten hier an
der herdenimmunität und deswegen nehme
ich sie jetzt in die Pflicht lassen sie
sich impfen für die Kinder die
Jugendlichen für unsere Freiheit ich
kämpfe für die allgemeine Impfpflicht ab
18 denn impfen darf keine individuelle
Entscheidung mehr sein es ist keine
vielen Dank
wir sind ja hier tendenziell
zurückhaltend mit der Einordnung von
reden aber ich glaube das konnte man
schon eine Wutrede nennen von Emilia
Fetzner aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen die sich für eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht ab 18 ausgesprochen hat
nächste Rednerin wird sein Simone
Borchert
aus der
unionsfraktionen
im Präsidium die Leitung dieser Sitzung
gewechselt hat Petra Pause die nächsten
zwei Stunden und dann ist wieder katrin
Göring-Eckardt dran
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
unser
Bundesgesundheitsminister möchte eine
Impfpflicht einführen dabei sind sie
sich als Regierungsparteien selbst sehr
uneinig da ist mittlerweile ganz
verschiedene Anträge aus ihren Reihen
gibt hier geht das Spektrum vom
Impfpflicht ab 18 bis impfpflich ab 50
oder gar keine Impfpflicht und hier
sehen wir sehr sehr deutlich dass es
keine klare und strategische Ausrichtung
der jetzigen Regierungsparteien gibt
und sehr geehrter Herr Lauterbach sie
werden ja gar nicht müde immer wieder
die hohen inzidenzzahlen ins Feld zu
führen um somit die Impfpflicht
durchzusetzen aber auch in der
Wirtschaft trifft man keine
strategischen Entscheidung nur anhand
einer Kennzahl und ich möchte Sie daher
bitten hier in Zukunft auch den
Schweregrad der Erkrankung zu
berücksichtigen dieser ist gerade nicht
vorhanden und auch die
hospitalisierungszahlen sind gerade
völlig unauffällig Inzidenzen alleine
bilden die pandemische Entwicklung nicht
sachgerecht ab und verzehren das Bild
auch in der Bevölkerung und führen zu
Inakzeptanz
der Antrag der cdu/csu sorgt dafür dass
wir genau diese wichtigen Zahlen im
Blick behalten werden und bei Bedarf
dann reagieren können
außerdem ist aufgrund der Impfungen
sowie der schon erfolgten Infektionen
der Immunschutz in der Bevölkerung
weitaus höher da hilft es auch nicht den
genesenen Status einfach mal so zu
verändern Kollegen Borchert gestatten
Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung der
Kollegin Vogler
Frau Kollegin Borchert ich habe eins bei
ihrem Antrag beim Antrag ihrer Fraktion
und auch bei ihrem Vortrag jetzt immer
noch nicht verstanden
der cdu/csu muss doch auch bewusst sein
dass bis zum Erreichen des vollen
Impfschutzes mindestens drei Impfungen
mit jeweils einem Abstand von drei bis
vier fünf sechs Monaten erforderlich
sind und insofern insofern frage ich sie
ob es wirklich eine kluge Idee ist mit
dem Einsetzen einer Impfpflicht zu
warten bis eine neue sehr gefährliche
möglicherweise tödliche Variante sich
gebildet hat und sich in Deutschland
verbreitet wie wollen Sie dem denn dann
entgegentreten können
vielen Dank für Ihre Frage aber es hilft
auch nicht wenn wir immer sagen was wäre
wenn
und deshalb denke ich dass die dass
dieses Gesetz zur impfvorsorge das
einzig Richtige ist weil wenn wir uns an
den richtigen Fakten orientieren wollen
dann orientieren wir uns an
inzidenzzahlen an der Schwere der
Erkrankung an den hospitalisierungsraten
und da komme ich gleich noch drauf auf
die Inhalte auf ein impfregister und das
ist der einzig richtige Weg woher wollen
wir denn wissen jetzt ohne impfregister
wer wann und wie oft geimpft ist
wir halten schon jetzigen Zeitpunkt eine
Impfpflicht unter den aktuellen
Gegebenheiten für nicht zielführend die
corona-pandemie stellt uns vorher
Herausforderungen und wir müssen unser
Gesundheitssystem flexibel und
reaktionsfähig halten und aus diesem
Grund hat die
cdu/csu-bundtagsfraktion den Antrag auf
ein im vorsorgegesetz gestellt und hier
liegen für uns die Zentrale in Punkte in
einem impfregister und wenn ich hier
höre immer das gesprochen wird von einer
geringen Impfquote dann frage ich mich
wo haben wir diese Daten her alleinig
mit einem impfregister während wir
transparent und hätten eine gute
Datengrundlage
die cdu/csu möchte eine gute
Impfkampagne und bei Bedarf natürlich
ein impfmechanismus der greift wenn es
notwendig ist
in den Jahren der Pandemie haben wir
dazu gelernt und dieses Wissen müssen
wir jetzt nutzen um uns für die Zukunft
aufzustellen und die Rahmenbedingungen
der Politik verändern sich im Zuge der
Entwicklung der Pandemie ständig aber
sehr geehrter Herr Minister und auch
Herr Habeck sie blenden die veränderten
Rahmenbedingungen für mich komplett aus
und wir fordern hier mehr Wissenschaft
mehr Flexibilität und weniger Starrsinn
vielen Dank
Simone Borchert noch mit einem
Redebeitrag das Brötchen gerichtet wird
ja wir haben hier eine Debatte zu
Gruppen und fraktionsanträgen und alle
haben das Recht auch Redebeiträge zu
Protokoll zu geben ich bin aber auch
gehalten dafür zu sorgen dass einerseits
das waagerecht
stattfinden kann aber nicht die
Redebeiträge sich verdoppeln oder
verdreiferin deshalb lasse ich in der
Regel oder frage ich in der Regel ob
eine Frage oder Bemerkung zugelassen
wird innerhalb einer Rede zwischen einer
Minute und drei Minuten aber nicht eine
zweite und dritte jeder hat ja die
Chance eine Beiträge oder
Meinungsäußerung auch noch zu Protokoll
zu geben
zum Sitzungsverlauf von
bundestagsviz-präsidentin pietrampau die
sich den ganzen Tag und den morgigen
auch hier in der Leitung des Bundestages
sind die Aufgabe teilt mit Katrin
Göring-Eckardt drei Vize bzw auch die
Bundestagspräsidentin sind an Coco wird
19 erkrankt eine vierte
viel zu Präsidentin ist einfach so krank
hätte ich jetzt was gesagt aber das ist
ja auch nicht besser kW Mansouri ist am
Pool für die SPD-Fraktion mit dem
Rechtsausschuss und er unterstützt den
Antrag von Dirk Wiese und Heike Behrendt
zum Beispiel also die Impfpflicht ab
schwere Verläufe Überlastung der
Krankenhäuser Patientinnen und Patienten
die auf Behandlung warten müssen
Einschränkungen des öffentlichen und
privaten Lebens in den Kitas und Schulen
in den Betrieben in der
kulturgastronomie und im Sport und
Menschen die unnötig sterben werden ich
finde das sind die schlechteren
Alternativen
und wenn ich als und wenn ich als Anwalt
hinzufügen darf sie sind auch nicht
Grundrechts schonender seit zwei Jahren
erleben wir jetzt eine endlosspirale aus
infektionswellen und Schutzmaßnahmen das
Land ist müde davon Eltern die keine
Planbarkeit haben Pflegekräfte die am
Ende sind und nicht mehr können diese
Spirale muss Enden wer
freiheitsbeschränkende Maßnahmen im
Herbst verhindern will der muss die
Impfquote jetzt erhöhen und nicht erst
im Herbst meine Damen und Herren
zu Beginn der Pandemie da war wenig über
das Virus und das Infektionsgeschehen
bekannt aber wie viele Wellen braucht es
denn noch um eine allgemeine
impfnachweispflicht zu regeln und wie
viel Solidarität wollen Sie denn noch
von Kindern und Jugendlichen von jungen
Menschen abverlangen die sich seit zwei
Jahren einschränken um andere Menschen
in diesem Land zu schützen ich finde das
muss jetzt aufhören meine Damen und
Herren und ich für meinen Teil ziehe
daraus auch Konsequenzen für mein
politisches Handeln und ich will hier
auch einräumen dass ich meine Haltung
gegenüber eine allgemeine
impfnachweispflicht geändert habe ich
finde das zeichnet eine demokratische
Debatte auch aus denn wir wollen hier
keine Glaubenssätze austauschen sondern
Argumente auf der Basis von Fakten und
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen wenn
die Sachlage sich ändert muss auch die
Schlussfolgerung eine andere sein
und deswegen will ich drei Erkenntnisse
nennen erstens dass eine Impfung
zuverlässig vor einer schwerwiegenden
Erkrankung schützt ist erwiesen zweitens
erwiesen ist dass eine Vorerkrankung
nicht denselben Schutz vor
Wiederansteckung bietet wie eine
Grundimmunisierung durch Impfung
drittens es gibt mittlerweile Varianten
von COBIT die sich so schnell ausbreiten
dass selbst junge Menschen sich auf den
Intensivstationen finden obwohl sie ein
geringeres Risiko haben schwerwiegend zu
erkranken und diese Fakten gilt es zu
berücksichtigen wenn wir jetzt über das
für und wieder eine allgemeinen
Impfpflicht diskutieren und über die
Ausgestaltung ich für meinen Teil halte
den Gesetzesentwurf für die Einführung
einer allgemeinen impfnachweispflicht ab
18 für vorausschauend und richtig vor
allem bin ich davon überzeugt dass er
zeitlich befristet und beschränkt auf
drei Impfungen auch verfassungsgemäß ist
denn unser Grundgesetz verlangt von
einer staatlichen Maßnahme dass sie ein
legitimen Zweck verfolgt geeignet
erforderlich und angemessen ist um
dieses Ziel zu erreichen über den
legitimen Zweck und die Geeignetheit zur
Zweckerreichung dürfte hier kein
ernsthafter Dezenz bestehen sondern die
Debatte dreht sich vor allem um die
Erforderlichkeit und Angemessenheit
eines verpflichtenden impfnachweises und
das Sprechen die besseren Argumente und
darauf komme ich gleich für den
Gesetzesentwurf manche wenden ein keine
impfnachweispflicht oder eine für Teile
der Bevölkerung sein
milder schon darüber kann man streiten
aber es ist eben nicht gleich geeignet
um unsere Krankenhäuser im Herbst und
unsere allgemeine Freiheit zu schützen
und deswegen ist der Gesetzesentwurf den
nicht unterstütze auch erforderlich
meine Damen und Herren
und natürlich greift ein verpflichtender
Impfnachweis in die Grundrechte der
Menschen ein aber grundrechtsgüter
gelten eben nicht uneingeschränkt
sondern sie sind in ein Verhältnis
zueinander zu bringen und deswegen muss
man auch hier feststellen ja jeder hat
das Recht sich unvernünftig zu verhalten
aber dieses Recht endet wo Millionen
andere Jahre lang in ihrer Freiheit und
Lebensweise eingeschränkt werden
zeitlich befristet und beschränkt auf
drei Impfungen ist die Nachweispflicht
zumutbar und deswegen ist der
gesetzeswurf auch angemessen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sechs Millionen
Menschen sind mittlerweile an kovit
verstorben auch meine Tante ich will in
keiner Gesellschaft leben in der
corona-tote einkalkuliert sind die
impfnachweispflicht ab 18 weist einen
Weg aus der Pandemie gehen Sie bitte mit
herzlichen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
ich habe jemand Suri war das ja noch mal
deutlich gemacht hat warum er für die
Impfpflicht ab 18 ist also für den
Gesetzentwurf der hier unter Behrens und
andere läuft gelegentlich auch unter
Wiese und andere auch Janosch Damen hat
sich für diese Variante ausgesprochen
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und wir schauen und wieder in die
Notfallstation Günther Krings ist
rechtspolitischer Sprecher und jetzt am
Pult Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren auch die heutigen
Debatte hat uns einer Entscheidung über
das Ob das wie einer Impfpflicht nicht
wirklich näher gebracht und der
wichtigste Grund ist offensichtlich dass
sie noch immer in der tiefen
Zerrissenheit bei diesem Thema sind
innerhalb der Ampelkoalition
und die verstecken das hinter
gruppenanträgen das kann man machen aber
es ist eben die Folge aber mit der
dramatischen
weltpolitischen Lage schwindelt
schwindet endgültig das Verständnis für
diesen adventismus der Bundesregierung
in dieser zentrale innenpolitischen
Frage
und offensichtlich
durchzieht diese Zerrissenheit in ihrer
Koalition ja die gesamte corona-politik
das andere Prominente Beispiel diese
Sitzungswoche ist die Novellierung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes
die Verbände hatten hier für ihre
Beteiligung und Stellungnahme knapp neun
Stunden in der Nacht und im Text nehmen
Sie den Ländern fast alle
Handlungsmöglichkeiten zur
pandemiebekämpfung und das alles bei
extrem steigenden ansteckungszahlen ein
Ministerpräsident der SPD wohlgemerkt
sprach davon man werfe hier den
Feuerlöscher mitten im Brand Weg meine
Damen und Herren
ich weiß auch nicht ob wir schon dankbar
sein sollen dass sie es überhaupt beim
Infektionsschutzgesetz zu einem
Regierungsentwurf gebracht haben und
nicht uns auch da mit gruppenanträgen
konfrontiert haben meine Damen und
Herren
aber wie passt das jetzt eigentlich
zusammen wenn die Ampel Mehrheit die
meisten Schutzmaßnahmen schleift und
eine große Mehrheit innerhalb der Ampel
zugleich eine sofortige Impfpflicht
einführen will hat den Eindruck bei
diesen beiden Themen bewegen sich in
zwei Paralleluniversen meine Damen und
Herren
deshalb mein Appell jedenfalls bei der
Impfpflicht wäre es doch gut wenn Sie
ausnahmsweise auf die Stimme der
Vernunft hören und die besagt erstens in
der jetzigen omicronwelle käme die
Einführung einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht
schlichtweg zu spät und zweitens dass
die Anordnung einer Impfpflicht die dann
im Herbst gegen ein neu-virusvariante
wirken soll zumindest eben heute noch
nicht so rechtfertigen ist ja impfen ist
der zentrale Weg aus der Pandemie und
dennoch ist die Pflicht zur Impfung ein
Grundrechtseingriff und da lässt sich
eben nur rechtfertigen mit der Überlast
unseres Gesundheitssystems dass wir das
verhindern wollen
dass sich eine Pflicht zur Impfung dann
nur auf die jetzt verfügbaren Impfstoffe
beziehen kann deren Wirkung auf
künftiger Varianten wir noch gar nicht
kennen können das führt dazu dass eben
die Geeignetheit nicht gegeben ist
verfassungsrechtlich und bei
Entscheidungen unter Unsicherheit darf
der Gesetzgeber auch nicht voreilig
entscheiden sondern muss zunächst die
verfügbaren Erkenntnisse zusammentragen
und sachgerecht bewerten genau das
fordern wir bis dahin ist eben eine
Impfpflicht auch nicht erforderlich im
Sinne des Verfassungsrechts meine Damen
und Herren
sehr wohl erforderlich ist aber das Bund
Länder und Kommunen jetzt ihre
Hausaufgaben machen und die
Vorbereitungen für eine möglicherweise
später notwendige Impfpflicht treffen
das reicht von der Stärkung der
Infrastruktur bis hin zum Aufbau eines
nationalen im Registers was wir jetzt
brauchen ist also keine Impfpflicht auf
Vorrat sondern ein vorsorgegesetz meine
Damen und Herren
und auch das kann ich nicht ersparen
bleibt die Vorlage eines solchen
Gesetzes oder eines solchen
Gesetzentwurfes natürlich die ureigenste
Aufgabe der Bundesregierung dafür gibt
es Sie meine Damen und Herren
in einer zentralen Frage
innerhalb der größten Krise der
Nachkriegszeit in innenpolitischer
Hinsicht muss die Bundesregierung sich
endlich ihrer Verantwortung stellen
meine Damen und Herren
und sie wäre klug beraten wenn sie dabei
unserem zweistufen-modell folgt auch
sachlichen und verfassungsrechtlichen
Gründen aber auch weil es der einzig
realistische Weg ist der uns die
sinnvolle Option nicht mehr und nicht
weniger die sinnvoll Option für eine
Impfpflicht erhält ich fordere daher die
Regierung auflegen sie einen
Regierungsentwurf für ein im
vorsorgegesetz zügig vor und die
Probleme mit der bisherigen
berufsbezogenen Pflicht das rückrudern
in Österreich das zeigt doch es reicht
doch nicht einfach eine Impfpflicht
anzuordnen wenn dann muss sie auch gut
vorbereitet sein meine Damen und Herren
vielen Dank
Günther Krings war das für die
Unionsfraktion der hier noch mal
juristische und auch verfassungsaspekte
eingeworfen hat in die Diskussion und
sie haben gesehen möglicherweise schon
unser Bild im Bild wie wir das nennen
wir erwarten in Kürze eine
Pressekonferenz vom Bundeskanzler Scholz
mit Nato-Generalsekretär stolpenberg vor
ihren Gesprächen heute und wenn die
beginnt geben wir natürlich live auf
dieses Signal 1 sein aber noch
impfpflichtdebatte im Bundestag mit
Katrin Göring-Eckardt
sie zweifeln hier daran dass das
Parlament wir als Parlament nicht
selbstbewusst genug ist gemeinsam eine
Entscheidung in einer so wichtigen Frage
zu treffen das verstehe ich nicht
zweitens und darauf bin ich gerne
Hinweisen wir haben ja jetzt seit zwei
Jahren Pandemie und nicht zwei Jahre
lang hat die Ampelkoalition hier
miteinander regiert am Anfang der
Pandemie haben wir als Bündnis 90 die
Grünen auch andere Fraktionen immer
wieder gesagt ja wir machen es hier im
Parlament gemeinsam wir stützen einen
Kurs den wir gemeinsam entwickelt haben
unabhängig davon welcher Fraktion oder
welcher Partei wir angehören in dieser
Frage bleibt und ist das zentral dass
wir hier als Parlament gemeinsam in
einem vernünftigen Kompromiss eine gute
Lösung finden das sage ich bevor ich
begründe warum ich für die Impfpflicht
ab 18 bin Kollegen gehören Eckert
gestatten so eine Frage oder Bemerkung
des Kollegen Kriegs es soll sein obwohl
ich weiß dass ich selbst hinterher
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin da sie mich
angesprochen haben wollte ich gerne
darauf auch mit einer Frage reagieren
sie haben kritisiert dass ich kritisiere
das ist kein Regierungsentwurf gibt sind
sie bereit zur Kenntnis zu nehmen dass
ich sehr wohl der Auffassung mit Ihnen
bin dass nur diese Entscheidung
Impfpflicht ja nein oder wie oder welche
Modellen natürlich nur hier im Bundestag
von uns als Abgeordneten zu treffen ist
das aber die Regierung in der Pflicht
steht in dieser zentralen Frage einen
Regierungsentwurf zu machen und erlauben
Sie mir zugleich dass ich daran erinnere
dass wir bei dem Thema einer
berufsbezogenen Impfpflicht auch keine
gruppenanträge haben und damit verbinde
ich die Frage sind Sie der Auffassung
dass Krankenpfleger Ärztinnen und Ärzte
das deren Grundrechte weniger relevant
sind das also da ein Regierungsentwurf
geht und ansonsten wir aber
gruppenanträge machen müssen aus Gründen
der Sensibilität der
grundrechtsensibilität worin liegt der
Unterschied
ich beginne mit dem mit dem zweiten weil
mich das auch sehr umtreiben nämlich die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht und das
viele der Menschen die dort arbeiten das
Gefühl haben wie so wir und nicht alle
anderen mich bringt das dazu dass ich
die einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht da
habe ich auch meine Meinung übrigens
geändert in den letzten Wochen Monaten
dass die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht der erste Schritt ist zu
einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht darum geht
es und zu ihrer zweiten Frage Herr
Krings man kann jetzt auch noch weiter
ich weiß nicht wie lange wochenlang über
das Verfahren reden mir wäre wichtig
dass wir über die Sache reden und eine
Entscheidung treffen das ist das worauf
es jetzt ankommt
und deswegen sage ich ja ich habe meine
Meinung geändert ich dachte es geht
freiwillig und es geht mit niedrigeren
Quoten das war ja bei anderen Varianten
auch der Fall das ist jetzt nicht mehr
so die Welt hat sich dramatisch
verändert aber eins ist geblieben
nämlich Corona das Virus ist mitnichten
verschwunden im Gegenteil die
Infektionszahlen sind so hoch wie nie
kein Tag vergeht an dem nicht eine
Tochter Partnerin Partner
Arbeitskollegen gute Freundin davon
berichtet dass es jetzt zwei Striche
sind auf dem Schnelltest Corona trifft
Familien die Schulen Krankenhäuser wie
Wirtschaft und ja auch unser Parlament
und insbesondere im Sinne der Kinder
müssen wir jetzt endlich dafür sorgen
dass wir diese Pandemie dieses Auf und
Ab dieses Hin und Her dieses Mal
Lockdown und mal Freiheit dieses Mal
Maßnahmen und mal keine mehr endlich
beenden und wir haben dieses eine
scharfe Schwert noch in der Hand dieses
eine scharfe Schwert ist die allgemeine
Impfpflicht und ich rufe sie auf mit uns
dafür zu morgen dass wir in diesem Land
die Freiheit zurückgewinnen denn genau
darum geht es ich will
ich will das nein es geht nicht um
Freiheit durch Zwang sondern es geht
darum dass eine Minderheit nicht
diktieren kann wie eine Mehrheit in
diesem Land lebt und wir haben
wir haben nun wirklich alles daran
gesetzt dass das impfenfreiwillig
passieren kann und jeder wird sagen
manche Kampagne hätte besser und schicke
und ich weiß nicht was sein können aber
inzwischen weiß jede und jeder das
Impfen schützt und das jede und jeder
weiß ich habe eine Verantwortung man
kann sie wahrnehmen oder nicht und für
diejenigen die sie bisher nicht
wahrgenommen haben da gibt es welche die
haben ernsthafte Bedenken und Sorgen
manche können es übrigens nicht manche
können es nicht und es gibt Menschen die
in diesem Land seit zwei Jahren kaum vor
die Tür gehen können auch für die müssen
wir sagen allgemeine Impfpflicht und
zuletzt meine Damen und Herren will ich
sagen es gibt ja einige besonders ihnen
nahestehende denen die allgemeine
Impfpflicht das im überhaupt immer ein
Riesenproblem war für die wird es jetzt
ein bisschen einfacher dann gibt es
nämlich eine Anweisung und dann muss man
das machen und auch damit glaube ich
sind wir ganz gut aufgehoben ich bin für
die allgemeine Impfpflicht ab 18 für
alle Erwachsenen das ist der Weg und
gerne reden wir über alle anderen
verfassungsgemäßen Varianten damit wir
hier gemeinsam zu einer guten
Entscheidung kommen herzlichen Dank
Katrin Göring für eine Impfpflicht aus
18 weil so sagt sie eine Minderheit
nicht diktieren darf wie die Mehrheit
lebt und deshalb ist sie wie gesagt für
den Antrag von Heike Behrens Dirk Wiese
janoschdamen und anderen
bei der vorletzten Redner in dieser
Debatte Matthias Helferich ist
fraktionslos
attestierte der
Bundesgesundheitsminister dr Karl
Lauterbach dem russischen
Staatspräsidenten per Ferndiagnose einen
narzisstische Persönlichkeitsstörung da
ich mir eine ähnliche psychoanalytische
Fachkompetenz wie der
Bundesgesundheitsminister zutraue
erlaube ich mir nun mal eine
Ferndiagnose das Münchhausen bei
proxy-syndrom ist eine Sonderform der
artifiziellen Störung bei der physisch
gesunde Personen beim anderen Menschen
häufig dem eigenen Kind Krankheiten
vortäuschen oder bewusst herbeiführen um
anschließend eine medizinische
Behandlung zu verlangen der Täter macht
das Opfer krank und dadurch Anerkennung
und Aufmerksamkeit zu erlangen auch wenn
keine Gefährdung für das Opfer durch
eine Krankheit besteht treibt es der
Täter in zahlreiche medizinische
Behandlung na kennen sie das
Krankheitsbild unmöglicherweise den
Erkrankten Herr Dr Lauterbach obwohl
inzwischen zahlreiche echte Experten
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht ablehnen
wird der Bundesgesundheitsminister samt
seiner Jünger nicht müde diese immer und
immer wieder lautstark zu fordern
gewichtige Stimmen wie die von den
Professoren Kallen streek kekulele oder
Stör die eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
gegen das Coronavirus sowohl medizinisch
als auch juristisch ablehnen werden
ignoriert weil es ihnen ja längst gar
nicht mehr um Gesundheitspolitik in
diesem Land geht sie wissen dass sie und
ihre Warnung ihr Wirken als mächtige
Dressur Elite mit dem Auftauchen von
Omicron beendet sind Omicron macht das
Virus schwach Omicron macht aber auch
sie schwach und nach zwei Jahren der
angstpolitik haben sie Angst Angst vor
dem bedeutungs
sie haben nun eine Chance sich an einem
Heilungsprozess in unserem Land unser
verletzten Gesellschaft zu beteiligen
indem sie die Menschen endlich in Ruhe
lassen und ihnen ihre Freiheit
vollumfänglich zurückgeben stimmen Sie
daher gegen jede Form des impfzwangs und
beenden sie die Herrschaft des
Münchhausen
stellvertretersyndroms in der
bundesdeutschen Gesundheitspolitik
vielen Dank
Matthias Helferich war das in
Argumentation und Wortwahl erkennbar als
afd-mitglied im Bundestag fraktionslos
unter anderem weil er sich einmal selbst
als das freundliche Gesicht des
Nationalsozialismus bezeichnet hat und
weil er auch ENA hat der Partei unter
radikalismusverdacht steht also ist er
hier nicht mehr Mitglied der Fraktion
aber natürlich noch Mitglied der Partei
Karl Lauterbach der
Bundesgesundheitsminister ist der letzte
Redner in dieser Debatte hoffen wir dass
wir in komplett hinkriegen das haben wir
eine lange und aus meiner Sicht gute
Debatte gehabt es gab ein paar Tiefpunkt
es gab auch sehr gute weitere wo stehen
wir jetzt naja wir müssen uns vor Augen
führen es hat sich nicht viel verändert
wir haben die fünf Szenarien vor uns die
im Herbst kommen können was Christian
Drosten beschrieben hat in seiner
hausarbeitung auch für Mitglieder des
Bundestags dass wir im Herbst vielleicht
möglicherweise wieder eine omicon-welle
bekommen dass wir vielleicht eine Delta
Varianten
Welle bekommen weil derzeit die
Impfquote in Afrika nur 14 Prozent ist
und dort sehr viel data sich wieder
ausbreitet wir können alle weiter
entfernte Variante bekommen wir können
eine
delta-kombinationsvariante bekommen und
was sehr gefährlich wäre und nicht
unwahrscheinlich ist dass sich ormicron
weiterentwickelt und einfach tiefer in
die Lunge eindringt weil es sind nur
ganz wenige Mutationen die das derzeit
verhindern die können jederzeit verloren
gehen
wir starten Sie eine Frage oder
Bemerkung des Abgeordneten Brandner
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir eine
dieser Varianten sehen geht an fast 100
Prozent die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir
im Herbst keine Schwierigkeiten haben
die corona-pandemie zu bekämpfen liegt
bei fast null Prozent das ist fast so
wahrscheinlich als dass wir gar keinen
Herbst bekämen daher wir müssen uns
vorbereiten was wird also im Herbst auf
uns zukommen im Herbst werden wir erneut
die Frage stellen müssen wird unser
Gesundheitssystem überlastet sein was
können wir tun um dieser Überlastung
begegnen zu begegnen was müssen wir
schließen wir gehen wir mit den
Geschäften um was können wir unseren
Kindern erneut zumuten sind die
Pflegekräfte da die wir benötigen wir
können ja nicht die vielen ungeimpften
die dann Behandlung benötigen und sie
auch bekommen werden den können wir ja
nicht sagen ihr hättet euch ja impfen
lassen können wir behandeln uns nicht
wir sind eine zivilisierte Gesellschaft
das heißt wir werden diese Menschen die
zum Teil selbst Fortsetzung größten Teil
sogar sehr schön wir werden sie
behandeln müssen und dann wird erneut
das ganze Land in der Geiselhaft dieser
Gruppe von Menschen sein die sich
einfach gegen die wissenschaftliche
Evidenz der weltweiten Forscher der
weltweitenbehandlungsforscher im
Forscher durchsetzen wollen die im
Prinzip noch stolz darauf sind dass das
Land auf See wartet ob sie sich impfen
lassen oder nicht das können wir uns aus
meiner Sicht nicht mehr lassen wir
müssen einmal Rücksicht nehmen auf die
Kinder wir müssen Rücksicht nehmen auch
die Pflegekräfte wir müssen Rücksicht
aufnehmen auf diejenigen die um ihre
Existenz kennen jetzt geht es darum dass
mal diejenigen die Regeln beachten die
ist all die Zeit nicht getan hat da kann
man natürlich die Frage stellen wirken
die Impfungen überhaupt oder nicht das
wissen wir doch wir wissen dass all die
Varianten die wir dich gerade aufgezählt
habe all diese Varianten sind genetisch
zu über 90 Prozent identisch daher
wirken doch alle Impfstoffe die zwei
Jahre alten Wuhan Impfstoffe verhindern
nach wie vor schwere Krankheit und Tod
natürlich verhindern sie nicht in jedem
Fall die Ansteckung aber das Problem der
Ansteckung ist ja nicht das Hauptproblem
wenn wir nicht schwer krank werden oder
sterben es geht doch hier darum schwere
Krankheit und Tod zu verhindern und
dafür haben wir die Impfstoffe die
müssen wir einsetzen und ich komme auf
die Vorschläge der CDU Herr Kings hat es
ja gesagt Herr Quinns hat den hat ganz
klar darauf hingewiesen es stimmt die
Impfpflicht kommt zu spät für die
ommikomwelle das ist richtig aber ihr
eigener Vorschlag der würde doch dafür
sorgen dass die Impfpflicht für jede
weitere Quelle die noch kaum zu spät
kommt ihr Vorschlag ist doch der
Vorschlag dass wir ehrlich gesagt
wichtige Zeit verliert wir kommen nicht
weiter und ich komme damit eine letzte
Frage gestatten Sie eine Frage Bemerkung
der Kollegin Vogler das würde ich machen
ja ich würde sagen die eine zugelassene
von der Präsidentin erlaubte
Zwischenfrage gut eingeteilt vielen Dank
Herr Kollege Lauterbach
mir ist ein bisschen auch wir sind ja
gemeinsam unterwegs für dieses Thema
Impfpflicht ab 18 aber mir ist schon ein
bisschen aufgestoßen dass sie das so
sehr individualisieren müssten wir nicht
auch ein bisschen demütiger darauf
gucken was die Politik in in diesen
letzten zwei Jahren
falsch gemacht hat unterlassen hat nicht
hinreichend auf den Weg gebracht hat um
den Menschen das Vertrauen zu geben dass
diese Empfehlung die wir ihnen geben und
das wird so wie sie auffordern dass Sie
sich bitte bitte alle drei Mal impfen
lassen sollen das auch wirklich
umzusetzen müssen ich also mir wieder
strebt das einfach da auf diese diese
individualisierte Schuldzuweisung zu
machen ich glaube wir haben sie auch mit
gesellschaftlichen Prozessen zu tun und
wir müssen nach der Pandemie oder nach
dem was wir jetzt alles zu entscheiden
dringend darüber reden unser
Gesundheitswesen solidarischer und
gerechter aufzustellen damit Menschen
auch wieder mehr Vertrauen haben
ja vielen Dank Frau Vogler sie haben
Recht
Schuldzuweisungen sind fehl am Platz
aber
verantwortungszuweisungen sind richtig
und die ungeimpften tragen derzeit die
Verantwortung dafür dass wir nicht
weiterkommen und das muss man sagen
dürfen das ist auch nicht ehrlich und im
übrigen wir müssen auch nach vorne
blicken natürlich sind auch Fehler
gemacht worden natürlich sind auch
Fehler gemacht worden aber wo stehen wir
denn jetzt wir sind jetzt zum ersten mal
20 22 ist das erste Jahr wo wir
tatsächlich die Pandemie für Deutschland
leider nicht weltweit aber wir können
die Pandemie für Deutschland zum ersten
Mal beenden mit der Impfung mit der
Impfpflicht lassen wir uns doch diese
Gelegenheit ergreifen wir haben sie
jetzt
wenn